[Music]
hey
what's up g cutie big shot big iso guy
and you watching on the rocks on the
ross take one
this the tongue tour the big brother
piece
you know what i'm saying is how we go
about too big man it is what you can
hear is how loud a lot
it's a statement piece i had to get this
i'ma get some little brother challenge
for the members you know
they call me some wrecks a lot
i can't i don't even know too much
panic 10 17. this one got a lot of
meaning to deal with my first chime
my first pendant it was a moment where
it was just this
in the rope gucci reached out to me uh
middle of the night couldn't believe it
at all got up i had to go to my manager
house
it was the first time he gifted me i got
my change and got signed around corona
so
he mailed it to me along with my cartier
cartier
ain't no price on oh no guilt like
priceless
ain't going over it ain't getting took
or nothing
obviously gucci is an icon in the
jewelry game
most definitely he's been known for
crazy pieces
big stupid diamonds and the best of the
best diamonds
he most definitely inspired me on juror
for sure
is there anyone else that inspired you
with their jewelry no
let's talk about the other card there
yeah
it's track color he like 20 minutes old
news
i ain't even put it on yet this is
something i really like i like the face
and look of them
i play with these i can give this to my
little bro tomorrow
if i want to it's all on you it's just
behind me feeling
i don't know folks take jared too
seriously
this a new pen after fuji y'all know got
signed and after i was able to get my
little cousin sign
because this is so icy boy apparently so
it's for alder so i suppose
you know what i'm saying the cuban one
of these two
was a gift too this one
the big one gucci
he upgraded my time had to go see the
drill take out the whole tank get some
fresh
switch it up you know it's a road goal
it look white it's rolled gold though i
bought this one myself
i prefer a little rose you know i just
like sauce and some
everybody ain't got for real but just
like trying to be different in there
everybody go all white big boy
this too new like this ain't even like a
couple days old
it's new this don't play with me
like i got some money now you buy my own
stuff man don't
don't play with me you're one of them
yeah bracelet id bracing is new
both of these bracelets know this one's
real new i bought this one like
a little after i got my cartier the
guilty jump
when i had to get something to
compliment you know i went to go get
this these kind with a ring a matching
ring
this is really what i guess in it
[Music]
these earrings they knew i ain't my ear
is not even perishing
i just got them with the big brother
time so i told you this like a couple
days old these two
they came together i call these them
that award
go watch all about the benjamin it's a
reason i
have no hearing reasoning so i can go do
this
hey brother i appreciate y'all for
checking out my jury collection
i'm gonna get up with y'all next time